Happiness Is What We Make It To Be.
We all talk of marriage and the birth of our children as a major "life moment".
Nothing personal, but as a single person, where do you get that kind of joy?
Do you have a "life lesson" that has changed you or your life, good or bad?
The best lesson that I've got so far is that...
...life is short and we should enjoy our life as much as possible!
No offense to married women like you, who spend most of their time taking care of the family.
But what I'm saying is that we don't even have enough time on this planet to be, for example, stressed out!
Hate is also a wasted time spent...
...and no vengeance is justified.
Love is everything,...
...whether it is love for a sister, mom, dad, husband, children, or friends.
Laughing is better than yelling at someone, or crying in sorrow.
We should also be grateful for our health and that we are not in pain.
For every breath we take is a blessing if it is not in pain.
Look on the bright side of every negative thought...
...and we will have the answer to the question, "Why should I be grateful?"
The answer is, "Because no matter how bad it is, it could be worse."